we are going to bounce now over to our
field correspondent I've labeled her the
senior roving Hall correspondent
Josephine Chang is out there on the hood
floor to experience some of the great
demos for herself lutely senior because
you hear the buzz around me that's
because there's more than a hundred
people in here now for demo fest they
actually get to lay their hands on the
actual products like Cortana or lab of
things and we are fortunate to have
Evelyn's villegas here with us and
you're going to demonstrate something
called coda lab so briefly explain what
code 11 Thank You Josephine so could a
lab is an open source platform for
machine learning research which allows
you to learn from other researchers to
share data and code and also to create
experiments and collaborate with others
that's one aspect and the other aspect
is about being able to some benchmark
infatuated competitions so let's see
what you mean let's say that a
researcher comes to your site and then
what we wanted a this is where you found
this is food a lot org and then I'm
going to show right now what aspects
which is the first aspects about
worksheets but we call worksheets which
is about sharing data sharing code and
really about doing an experiment and
showing others how you went about
solving our problems so for instance if
I look at the specific worksheet which
was created by Percy Leon which by the
way for I here this morning Brazilian is
from Stanford University and she might
not be a one winner right back you and
so his vision for potala really comes
from a person who is sort of a community
lead so this is just an example this
Lewis Carroll poem and what this is just
an example so sheer actually what you do
is like you just for this example I want
to see how I'm going to take a poem some
text and I want to parse it the feet of
natural language processing so i can
describe what i do so somebody else can
come and exact what i'm doing so parsing
you mean to like figure out either what
it means or to analyze exactly sources
if you look at this little text here
what we're going to do is just like
decompose this text in terms of figuring
out what are the top
what are the words what are the Serbs
denounce the actions events and so funny
that's a funny poem twinkle twinkle
little bat how I wonder what you're at
up above the world you fly like a tea
tray in the sky now do you want to know
where the determiners the nouns verbs
are okay so I want to know what the poem
means right what I'm going to show you
today is just like you can actually use
some libraries from somewhere else in
the word and apply them to your problem
so that's what we do here for it so with
these libraries you discuss the process
you can put some metadata so that other
researchers can actually do what you're
doing that's really about introducing a
research what I'm going to show you like
you know we also have a command-line
interface which means that you can run
it and then you can actually then
provide some output fear if I manage to
get there and which gives you hear all
those determiners and all that is not
these examples which is not easy to
understand why so you have a better way
to it indeed so now I'm when you know I
cannot really visualize all that I mean
I cannot read it's good for the machine
but not so much for me as a human right
for me indeed so we're going to go and
find some other libraries and now we're
going to apply some visualization
library and the first thing I just
showed you we done we're going to show
you now some little a visualization here
which is going to come up and where you
be able in a second here to to see right
so now those determiner there is a
determiner these are noun phrases as so
on and so forth dude in port that's just
an example I mean obviously they're not
going to be analyzing home so be
analyzing data sets and and why would
scientists want to share I mean aren't
aren't scientists sometimes a little
proprietary about their work what is so
good to be proprietary and to be you
know like wanted to keep it to yourself
at the very beginning what you are kind
of experimenting but as part of the
science process and
process you want to make sure that your
results can be validated by others and
that's the whole point chair and really
making it really really easy to be able
to do in producible research I want the
guys here I want to bring in here Isabel
guy on who is a researcher at child
learn she's someone who uses code allow
the customer basically so can you show
us like how you run competitions right
that that sort of allow scientists to
figure out what is the best solution to
a problem that's right I'm the president
of the channel which is an organization
dedicated to organizing challenges in
machine learning there are competitions
that which scientists can demonstrate
excellence and repeat that I'll show as
an example we put out a number of
problems so recently we put out a
competition on cause-effect bears the
participants had to determine whether
given some variables is a cause of b or
b ecause of a and they made a true
breakthrough be improved tremendously
compared to the baseline performance so
for example if a is smoking and be could
be lung cancer does a Cosby that's
correct you see lots of claims you know
in the media recently people claim that
the chocolate consumption was
influencing the brain because there was
an article in The New England of Journal
of Medicine where actually the
researchers should this correlation
between chocolate consumption and the
number of normal prices per capita oh
really well for that eat more chocolate
anyway let's see the results of the
competition like who won and what is
that I hear the winner is so starting
from performances there were near 0.5 so
Neil random the best up and entrance
made a big leap in performance that
error they already fell down and that
the accuracy is near eighty-two percent
and that you know an execution time
which is relatively modest the beauty of
Korolev is that it lets participants
submit their code so the code can be
benchmarked and both the speed is
measured as well as the accuracy that's
interesting so the competition lets them
arrive at answers quicker but also that
they can collaborate afterwards as to
who what good ideas that they have very
interesting work Thank You Evelyn and
you go to coda lab dot is a coda lab org
to try it out to register and try it out
Chris